on va terminer sur les initiatives
législatives dans votre département des
yvelines et pour en parler on va aller
du côté de versailles
merci beaucoup
mais c'est absolument doc éditeur du
site 78 kg et du courrier des il dit
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
et on va revenir avec vous sur les
résultats des législatives dans le
département des yvelines où sophie
primas là un peu 10 et 2 se sont mauvais
résultats reprend les républicains
oui complètement et c'est dans une terre
de droite et du centre les républicains
ont perdu
près de 50 mille votes c'est quand même
énorme on a aujourd'hui que des duels à
part dans la 9e circonscription on en a
12 ici on n'a que des duels du ps
ensemble donc il ya un vrai un vrai
tous les électeurs de l air sont en
train de partir vers la macro ni donc
c'est effectivement un événement en tous
les cas ce qu'on a vu dimanche soir est
quasiment exceptionnel
et comment on explique cet effondrement
des candidats les républicains dans ce
département alors qu'on le disait il
était solidement implanté il n'ya encore
peu
alors c'est non seulement il était
implanté mais les candidats choisis par
pierre béni le patron dé l'air dans le
département étaient des candidats plutôt
plutôt qu'ils connaissaient les dossiers
qui connaissait le terrain qui était soi
mais reçoit conseillers départementaux
donc
dire qu'il y avait de la compétence en
tous les cas et pour autant ils ne sont
peut-être quasiment jamais sur le podium
ou parfois parfois il arrive pas on
pense à ça alexandra dublanche apolline
winocour le faire dans l'ain vieme qui
qui connaît aussi bien la ruralité que
le député sortant et pourtant elle et
elle est loin l'eau loin du du de se
qualifier donc il ya un phénomène du ps
qui est évident puisque la du ps a fait
120 mille votants ce qui est énorme par
rapport à 2017
on est on est sur 80 milles de vote en
plus donc il ya un phénomène de rejet
les électeurs qui se sont quand même
rendu dans les yeux puisqu'on a un point
de moins en terme d' abstention ils se
sont rendus dans les urnes mais pour
dire on veut soit le pire sans trous
soit
ni baisse mais en tout cas pas le reste
et quand j'entends sophie primas dire on
avait raison de rester indépendant je
veux je me pose la question et je lui
pose la question
quand comment on va faire les nerfs pour
se sortir de ce de ceux de ce bloc de
ces blocs il dessine aujourd'hui on a
bien on a un gros bloc de gauche on les
voit on a un gros bloc centriste et on
n'a pas de bloc à droite donc même si
elle règne fait fort aussi dans le
département des yvelines
que peut faire changer de nom se met
dans un blog pour pouvoir pour pouvoir
exister politiquement c'est ça la
question
assez votre question bon d'abord je veux
dire que dans les yvelines vous avez
raison c'était une terre de droite mais
je pense que les élus de la république
en marche on en fait ont évidemment
capté 7 7 cet électorat de droite et en
fret dans les yvelines vous avez deux
catégories de population historique ça
veut dire vous avez et pardonnez moi de
le dire comme ça là là les électeurs des
manuels mâcon de la france qui va bien
voilà on a toute une partie des yvelines
avec les français qui vont bien qu'ils
sont des cadres supérieurs des cas des
patrons du cac40 j'ironise un peu dont
les enfants vont faire leurs études à
l'étranger enfin vous voyez un peu une
typologie et c'est très bien il en faut
je ne suis pas du tout mais présentant
en dix ans ça mais une france qui va
plutôt bien et on a une france plutôt
ouvrière plutôt rural plutôt modeste qui
est plutôt dans le nord des yvelines et
dans grant west d yvelines est là et
bien cette population-là a été la gauche
n'a pas disparu en réalité dans les
yvelines elle a été dissoute au moment
du parti socialiste du parti communiste
on a vu que les on n'a plus du tout par
exemple de circonscription n'avait plus
du tout circonscription socialiste par
exemple la circonscription philippe
benassaya ou de michel vialay était
historiquement des circonscriptions de
gauche est en fait c'étaient les
républicains qui avaient repris ces
circonscriptions là alors que la
république en marche avait repris les
circonscriptions de la france qui va
bien si j'ose dire donc
clairement si vous voulez maintenant les
législatives sont plus il ya plus de
relations territoriales dans les
législatifs ce que je déplore évidemment
un rythme infernal on a éloigné vraiment
le parlement des territoires et donc ce
n'est pas ce n'est pas
étonnant finalement qu'on ait la même
chose aujourd'hui dans ce scrutin un
vote qui soient éloignées du territoire
éloigné de personnes qui par ailleurs
ont été élu l'année dernière vous le
rappeler on avait on avait présenté nous
plutôt des conseillers départementaux
plutôt des maires de grandes villes etc
et ils ont été balayés alors qu'ils ont
été plébiscités l'année dernière donc
presque ça peut pas dire que le mal est
profond pour les as l'air parce qu'on
vous a beaucoup entendu pas vous hein
mais les républicains au lendemain de la
présidentielle d'hier mais les quatre 78
y ait un vote utile en faveur des
manuels m'a comblé c'est la meilleure
chance aux extrêmes est à bout de
souffle a juste que votre il ya une
déperdition voire une disparition de
votre électorat je crois pas nous moi ce
qui peut enfin moi ce qui me frappe et
quand vous me disais comment est ce que
les élèves vont pouvoir redémarrer et ce
alors bon moi je crois à la disparition
global du terme lr je crois une
restructuration notre partie profonde je
crois qu'il faut qu'on change de nom il
faut qu'on change voilà deux méthodes de
gouvets non ce qu'on change qu'on
rajeunisse voilà l'ensemble de notre de
notre gouvernance etc fait tomber johnny
lui-même de centre-droit ou une à droite
affirme tournée moi je crois qu'il faut
qu'on retrouve le goût du territoire
qu'on regroupe le goût de la proximité
on a des éléments plus ça va plus les
français détestent la politique parce
qu'ils en sont éloignées je pense que
c'est une erreur que l'on a fait depuis
quinze ans plus tôt la gauche que la
droite mais mais mais quand même qu'on a
fait collectivement d'éloigner le
parlement les élus du concitoyen je
pense que ça doit être notre ligne
principale de retrouver le lien avec les
citoyens
localement mais aussi au parlement je
pense que c'est fondamental dans
l'écriture d'une histoire d'amour entre
le parlement et le peuple et je pense
que là les républicains ont leur place à
faire on va remercier michel d'avoir été
avec nous et on va faire des lettres
duels ça qu'on va regarder
macron résiste à l'annulaire balayé
c'est à la une du courrier des yvelines
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous
[Musique]